depuis quelques mois les conducteurs de
bus du réseau stibus ont une routine un
peu différente qu'à leur habitude
maintenant leur bus fonctionnent au gaz
naturel il ouvre à la trappe il enlève
le bouchon et on a un pistolet à
disposition qu'on va brancher on se met
toujours en sécurité et on met on
enclenche le pistolet
et on ouvre la vanne pour le gaz et
voilà en mai dernier le dépôt de trappes
avait entamé sa conversion au gaz
naturel ce sont aujourd'hui 41 bus
roulant au biométhane qui sont en
circulation
un bus gnv est un bus qui bénéficient du
carburant gaz 1 comme comme tout à
chacun le gaz de ville et pour pouvoir y
accéder on a besoin d'un compresseur le
réseau stibus est composé de 38 lignes
globalement géographiquement ça concerne
la gare de trappes plaisir la verrière
elancourt plus écologique et moitié
moins bruyants ils réduisent de 80% les
émissions de co2 par rapport au diesel
ils vont remplacer progressivement les
bus les plus anciens et les plus
polluants un programme de transition
écologique à l'initiative de la ratp est
dite de france mobilité sans équivalent
en europe la région ile de france à
travers ile-de-france - 8 et a pour
objectif de devenir la première région à
atteindre la décarbonation totale de
l'ensemble des modes de transports en
commun de nombreuses nouveautés
améliorations je l'en citer
quelques-unes qui sont majeurs
trois portes au lieu de deux facilitant
ainsi le flux voyageurs s'ils valident
heures au lieu de trois des ports usb à
la disposition des voyageurs et des
places assises réservées aux personnes
âgées ou aux pmr matérialiser en rouge
avec plus de 13 millions de voyageurs
par an le réseau stibus entendent bien
se mettre au vert de quoi peut-être
aider à augmenter sa fréquentation en
baisse à cause de la pandémie depuis